within the span of about a decade
self-driving cars will be fairly
commonplace and they will redefine the
automotive world in at least ten ways at
least that's what McKenzie and company
are saying right now an automotive
industry expert Dominic we works there
you author a report of the same name and
joins me from Munich Dominic thanks so
much for spending some time let me ask
first of all you know I spent some time
in an automated autonomous outtie
recently and they said it would be
available at least a level three
availability meaning you still have to
take the wheel in case of an emergency
within the next couple of years do you
expect those cars that can drive us to
work as long as we're kind of paying
attention to come soon yeah most
certainly thanks a lot for having me
Matt most certainly we expect cars that
will do what we call partial autonomous
driving what you just called a level
three to be on the roads in the next
couple of of years and it's already
going to be a big step up from what we
use to today so and the headline number
from your report is how much time that
kind of thing is going to save us right
because we can then check our emails or
eat donuts or whatever and the average
human spends what 50 minutes a day
commuting yeah yeah so when we talk
about the 50 minutes we talk about full
autonomous driving right so this is not
what we just described in two or three
years time this is what we described
what's going to be maybe commonplace in
10 to 15 years it means the car goes
entirely on its own it's like a cap
without a cap driver you could literally
imagine having a car they can turn
around the seed and face backwards while
you're driving and so so obviously when
this is the case you do not need to
drive your car anymore when you're on
your way to work to the supermarket
going back every day so in the amount of
time that's the number you just talked
about is this 50 minutes every single
day you will be all over suspending in
the car it's time that's going to be
freed up 1.2 billion people driving cars
every single day if you multiply these
two numbers it's 2 times the man-hours
that it took to build the pyramids of
ESA so let's hope we spend that time in
a in a meaningful way I wonder you know
a lot of this technology is
available already it just needs to be
implemented regulation obviously
infrastructure how long do you think
it's going to be until we get to that
point yeah
so Andy as you mentioned a lot of the
technologies are already there but the
thing is until we have these cars
driving on the roads day to day a lot of
other things also need to be solved
right so for instance questions like
what happens if an autonomous driving
car crashes into a tree right or who
decides where the autonomous driving car
trasher so there's a lot of
infrastructure and leg Ettore regulatory
hurdles that still need to be overcome
and yeah we believe this full autonomous
driving until it's commonplace right we
won't be surprised seeing one on the
streets it's maybe 10 to 15 years out
your take on the insurance case I
thought was most interesting will no
longer ensure individuals rather the car
makers is that just at first or is that
the change the insurance industry is
going to see yeah so um yeah we believe
that the impact of autonomous driving is
going to go far beyond just the
automotive industry and indeed insurance
is a very good example and today
insurance companies they ensure
individuals millions of individuals
against human error right if you don't
drive your car yourself anymore there's
no need to insure yourself against human
error so what will happen instead is the
the companies that make the cars and
that are suppliers to the car industry
these companies we need insurance
against technical failure so the nature
of the risk that insurance companies are
insuring is going to change
fundamentally I wonder about there there
are two systems that are sort of played
right now Google has this system that
relies on data very obviously data heavy
from the street from other autonomous
vehicles around whereas mobile I the
Israeli company that's making strides
here has a system that relies on a
camera and a computer that reacts as a
human would which do you think is going
to set in first
hmm so I think in the end we are going
to see a fusion of all of these
technologies right because I mean as
today safety is going to be the most
important thing in driving and we
actually believe that road safety is
going to improve a lot with autonomous
driving so I think car makers will aim
for using the best of all of the
technologies available to make these
cars as safe as possible
alright Dominic thanks very much
McKinsey & Company principal Dominic we